THREE
GOALS IN
NIGHT BUG-A-BOOS FOR
THAT IS GETTING BACK IN THEHE TO
RESORTS.
TALK ABOUTILL TAKE IT AGAINST
JOE PAVELSKI..
>> Daryl: MAKAR'S SHOT GOE THOS
GOALS FROM
>> Daryl: ON THE REBOUND
OPPORTUNITY FOR
COLLISION.
HE IT GO AFTER
GI RAR SUTER.
THIRD STRAIGHT GAME FOR THE F A
THERE AS NOT ENOUGH O
BASICALLY IN ITS INFANCY RIGHT
NOW.
BEEN DYNAMITE IN T HOCKEY GAME.
LANDESKOG WHO OPENED LEFT WING .
IT'S HARD TO FIND A FLAWCHES OU.
>> Daryl: THERE'S THAT, CAN THEY
THRESET. STARS' TERRITORY.
TOWN THE RIGHT
AVS CAN HANDLE IT.
ROBERTSON AND HINTZ SWITCHING
WITH PAVELSKI.
TO THE CIRCLE, GOES
STARS HAD FULL CONTROL.
COULDN'T GET IT OUT.
THEY WORK IT I IN COLORADO TERR.
COMES I THINK